we've got to see yourself the way we
want to be and then we have to live with
it people so say you should slow down
that's a bunch of crap
we should speed up when we get into the
success zone everything that our life
starts to change you only have to know
two things you have to know where you're
going and you have to know that you're
going to get there
hello elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael mark one wouldn't believe I
believe that entrepreneurs will of all
of the world's major problems so that
helps on your journey today or would
alert from the law of attraction smack
there's Bob Proctor and might be honest
top tension to success all you remember
three is my personal favorite and I love
to know which ones you guys like the
best and as always as you're watching TV
shoot something that's pretty resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below so folks are others who can be
inspired by credit card as well and also
when you write it in much more likely to
stick for yourself as well
enjoy
see people don't resist change people
resist being changed eh yes we've got to
change yourself we've got to build a new
image a picture in our mind we've got to
see yourself the way we want to be and
then we have to live with it that's you
go to the gym work out that's what you
do you build a picture how you want to
see this our disarmed and you build that
picture and then you build the body
well you build the life in your mind
take your pen and write out how you want
to live and always start by writing I'm
so happy and grateful now that and the
second you write it you've got it
intellectually
the moment you impressive the prime your
emotional mind you've got it emotionally
and it's only a period of time till it
manifests on the physical plane
yes spirit it works my higher to a lower
potential let that little yellow dot on
the screen represent your level of
awareness this represents your level of
awareness this is what you're aware of
now everything you've got in your life
everything your relationships your money
everything is an expression of your own
level of awareness see people that are
in 50,000 a year or not earning 50
because they want 50 people are earning
50 because they're not aware of how to
earn 150 people that are suffering from
headaches they're not suffering
headaches because they want to suffer
from headaches they're suffering from
headaches because they're not aware of
how to eliminate the headache if their
head they made it eight they can make it
stop so you see it's awareness where
after now think of this if that little
dot represents our awareness and it's
responsible for everything we've got in
life just think of how your life could
change if we magnify it just a little
bit I mean everything would start to
change our relationships would change we
would be healthier we would live in
healthier bodies we would know more
people we'd earn more money we'd be able
to do more interesting things and if we
just increased it a little bit more
everything starts to shift well I've
been living this way now for 40 years it
absolutely fascinating I celebrated my
70th birthday last week I got more
energy than most
four-twenty I have absolutely no
intentions of slowing down
people should say you should slow down
that's a bunch of crap
we should speed up we've got more power
yet you know the most erudite scientist
alive can't even guess what you and I
are capable of doing no one knows what
we're capable of all the powers on the
present that's within you within me slow
down we're just starting to warm up what
we want to do is calm down you can go
out warp speed and stay very healthy if
you stay relaxed and that's really the
secret now just imagine we expand our
awareness a little more do you know what
this program is doing for you today it's
expanding your awareness that's what the
program is all about
every time you come every time you come
to one of these programs your awareness
is widened your world starts to change
you think oh yeah that's pretty
interesting and it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger our
awareness keeps changing you know that
no one knows how much money you're
capable of earning there's no one can
even guess at what you're capable of
earning we want to become aware we're
like we are because we're not aware of
how to do it better we know how to do it
better every person in this room
intellectually knows how to do a better
job they're doing everyone in the room
knows how to earn more than they're
earning but they're not doing it you see
having the knowledge is not the deal
having the knowledge I mean I remember
when I was a kid
schoolteachers say to me Bob why'd you
do that I'd say I don't know what do you
mean you don't know you know better I
know I did it I don't know I was in the
Navy every commanding officer Proctor
why did you do that I don't know sir
what do you mean you don't know you know
better I know why'd you do it I don't
know you see I didn't know why I was
doing things do you know that we do
things that we don't want to do it gives
us results we don't want to get yet we
do them anyway you know what addiction
is it's never getting enough of what you
don't want get a lot of people are
addicted
two results that they don't want why do
we keep doing it you see I think when we
start to see that that's when we start
to become aware of how to take control
over our life and that's really what we
want to do so you see awareness is the
big deal we want to become aware of the
obvious opportunities that are available
to us we are surrounded by opportunity
they're everywhere you go there is an
abundance there's no shortage of
opportunity we can win and we can win in
a big way
now when we lack awareness we miss the
opportunity I used to always say that
you know the trick is to be in the right
place at the right time I've been in the
right place at the right time many times
in my life but I blew it
you know why I wasn't aware that I was
in the right place with the right I had
to look back at it think of it there's
something else it's being aware that
you're in the right place at the right
times not good enough you've got to be
aware that you're in the right place at
the right time habits good habits will
give you results of stick bad habits
will destroy everything I have some bad
habits that's right all my habits are
not great so if you've got some bad
habits don't feel bad so does your
next-door neighbor so does your mentor
your coach so does your mother and
father Authority one and the trick of
life is to replace a bad habit with a
good habit I used to hang around bars
all the time and one day I went in I
picked up a glass and I looked around
and I thought they're all buns in here
and then it dawned on me I'm always here
ha ha
I learned something I put the glass down
they said I'm never coming back here
again and I'm never going to drink us
and I never did it was a long time ago
but you know what I did I went from
spending all my money in the bar to the
racetrack and I started to bet it all on
horses so I went from making somebody
with a bar get wealthy and then I
started to feed the horses and one day I
woke up and I learned something if you
don't consciously and deliberately
replace a bad habit
the good habit you will automatically
create another bad habit now what is a
habit a habit is an idea that has been
planted in the garden of your
subconscious mind and then repetitively
fed for a sufficient period of time that
you act on it without giving any thought
to it I'll give you an example I want
you to right now mentally imagine you're
pulling on your underwear in the morning
what foot you put in first I put my
right foot it if I tried to put my left
foot in my underwear first I'd stagger
and I'd fall over you me say what's this
got to do with it it's got everything to
do with it why do I put my right foot
you may put your left certainly a lot of
people do well when I was just a little
gaffer didn't have a clue of how to put
underwear on my mother or my grandmother
and my father or somebody came along and
they had the underwear I read put your
foot in here you're rather fought what
did they do they had the underwear
prepared as if they were going to put it
on and so pretty soon I was doing it
like they were doing it they through
repetition planted the idea in my hand
in my mind well now think of this you
don't just form habits of how to get
dressed you form habits to do everything
that you do and some of them are not
that productive any idea that you keep
dwelling on and impressing upon your
subconscious mind becomes fixed in the
subconscious mind a habit is nothing but
an idea that's fixed in the subconscious
mind that you act on without giving any
conscious thought many years ago I went
in to train the Prudential Insurance
Company of America their agents I ended
up training all of their agents and I
only got them to do two things this is
in the early 70s I got them to form the
habit of being in front of a prospect
before 9:00 a.m. and ask everybody they
talked to to purchase $100,000 worth of
insurance I said you don't have to sell
them just give them the opportunity to
say no you know the sales in that
company went up by hundreds of millions
of dollars Ida retired VP tell me he
thought it was a billion just changing
to
heavens what habit you want to change
I'm forever chat about habits I've got
I'm in the habit right now of changing
my diet and you know something I've been
doing it for going on three weeks it's
getting easier but it's still not that
easy it's still like the reach children
eat some of that when nobody's looking
doesn't work doesn't work I'm looking
what habit are you going to form and you
shouldn't drive for more than two at
once it'll become too big too heavy and
you won't for many make up your mind
you're going to do it every day every
day every day until you don't have to
think about it and then you'll
automatically do it I guarantee you this
idea will change your life think about
it all day because that is definitely an
idea
that will give you results that will
stick right now I'm standing in the
middle of my library this is my favorite
place you know Earl and you'll see that
you surround your mind with greatness
some of its going to rub up well
hopefully some of it is rubbed off on me
I have maybe three or four thousand
books here on the shelf they're all in
alphabetical order and by author they're
all catalogued so I know where to find
something just like that I go by authors
more than the title of the book you know
that when I started studying these books
I really didn't know very much about
anything I had two months high school I
was 26 years old at a bad work record a
bad attitude and and virtually no
experience and you know in a relatively
short period of time my income went for
four thousand one hundred and seventy
five thousand a year then we're over a
million I'm going to share some
information with you that it could
change the direction of your life like
night and day
and when I say that I want you to really
stop and take a look at your life take
an honest look at your life I was
thinking just before I start to make
this we have actually been conditioned
to kid with ourselves to lie to
ourselves to not really take an honest
look at the results we're getting I want
you to take a real honest look at your
results
and when you look at them ask yourself
am i living the way I really want to
live you see most people aren't one of
the first questions I ask a person that
comes to work with me I want to know
what's the most they've ever earned in a
year now I really don't care what the
answer is but I want to know what the
answer is because you see if if a person
says the most I've ever earned in years
$50,000 I know where their mind is
programmed and if they tell me the most
I've ever earned is two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars I know where
they're programmed and then I want to
find out what they want and I know then
what has to shift because their mind is
programmed and if they're really going
to live the way they want to live they
they've got to change the program and if
they don't change the program then
nothing really happens I want to suggest
that to make up your mind you're going
to get in what we call the success zone
yet it's a way of thinking now get this
if 95 96 percent of the population are
blowing it
if 1% of the population are earning
about ninety five percent of all the
money you're not going to get a whole
lot of people agree with what you're
doing most people are going to look at
you kind of strange what are you going
there for you went there last month what
are you listening to that for you listen
to that before what are you reading what
do you read the same book over and over
for they don't understand and you see
they're advertising their ignorance by
the questions they ask when we get into
the success zone everything in our life
starts to change but understand this
you're going to be a bit of an odd
you're out of the box you're not one of
the masses and when you get out of the
box
your whole world starts to shift there's
a box and there's a leader leader get
people excited about improving the
quality of whatever it is themselves
their work whatever they're doing people
follow leaders because they want to
people don't follow our leaders because
they have to that becomes a form of
dictatorship and that never works the
great leaders people want to
whoa and leaders inspired leaders pull
the very bust out of you leaders know
how to look inside and bring the best of
you to the service cause you to look at
a higher side of your own personality
what if the world always is looking for
its leader like it's silly - who's going
to lead the leader is going to lead and
the leader just automatically emerges if
they threw 50 of us into a committee and
say you don't have left a leader elect
one but the leader is going to lead that
probably isn't the one that's elected
yeah so true no there's no stop they
know how to get the best out of people I
want to talk to you about where you're
going and what you want to do with your
life you see most people never go after
what they want because they don't know
every step they have to take to get
there I want you to think of a person
going up the side of a wall of ice now
the only rule for reaching a goal that
you have to know is knowing where you're
going and knowing that you're going to
get there you do not have to know how
you're going to get there now pay
attention to this for a moment imagine
the climber has all his equipment he's
got his crampons he's got his climbing
rope his hardware his ice access how
does he get to the top he's standing on
the ground and he's looking at maybe a
hundred foot vertical wall of ice he
looks up and he has absolutely no idea
the path that he's going to take he just
sees himself at the top he reaches up
and he puts one pick in and then another
pick then he raises one foot and then
the other now he's not standing on the
ground any longer he suspended on the
wall on a vertical wall of ice that goes
up 400 feet he adapts to the changes
that is taking place in his environment
and then and only then does he see the
next step any
lose this pick then this pick then this
foot then this point now that's how he
gets to the top a step at a time and
that's how you're going to get to your
goal you just have to know the first
step to take and when you take that step
you're going to find that your
conditions your circumstance and
environment will change then you see how
you have to make the next step it's a
matter of adapting all the time
you only have to know two things you
have to know where you're going and you
have to know that you're going to get
there you've got to see it in your mind
now this is the beautiful scenario this
is what it's all about
save that in your mind and think of it
often think every time you think of your
goal and you're trying to figure out how
you're going to do it
think of that vertical wall of ice
what's the next step that's all you
really have to know one step at a time
and you'll get to wherever you're going
that's how Hillary got to the top of
Mount Everest in Napoleon Hills walks
thank you go rich he said now right here
we come to a rather strange fact we tend
to minimize the things we can do the
goals we can accomplish and for some
equally strange reason we think other
people can accomplish things up weekend
up any points out that there's a
difference between wishing proofing and
being ready to receive them said no
one's ready for a thing until they
believe that they can acquire it the
state of mind must be believed and not
mere over wish yeah he was under
consciousness and open-mindedness is
essential to belief closed minds will
not inspire faith courage orderly a
German engineer by the name of Karl Benz
at a fantasy and he literally turned his
fantasy into a fact and in January 1886
Karl Benz was issued a patent for the
Benz motor carry and the age of the
automobile had done this is a replica of
that magnificent machine and you know
before Benz ever turned his fantasy into
a theory even long certainly long before
he turned it into a fact he had asked
himself a couple of questions that you
and I and every other dreamer will have
to go through
he had to ask himself am i able to do
this well he seemed to have that innate
awareness of this higher self this image
of perfection within him and he saw
himself as a person that was actually
able to take and turn the fantasy into
effect now he must have been a pretty
courageous guy because there were no
horseless carriages in those days but
then he had to ask himself am I willing
and you see he'd ask himself am I
willing to accept the ridicule that I'm
bound to get am I willing to accept the
failures well he said yes I am willing
he was willing to pay the ultimate price
to turn his fantasy into a fact and
ridicule he got his own partner thought
he had gone mad and he had to find
himself a more congenial colleague to
work with he would take this thing out
in the evening he'd take it out at night
so no one would see him he escapes some
of the ridicule and time after time he
couldn't get it going
he had to push it back but it never
dawned on him that he would not
ultimately realize his dream when this
magnificent machine completed its first
long journey with bended wheel every
beat of the engines on an answering echo
in the heart of the driver as every turn
of the wheels brought him closer to his
goal so the realization all of what once
was a fantasy now in order for you to
turn your fantasies into a fact you have
to go through exactly the same process
as Carl Benz and if you do go through
the same process you'll meet with
exactly the same success regardless of
the opposition you might come up against
you have to ask am I able to turn this
fantasy of mine into a fact can I
actually realize it can i turn my dreams
into reality now you're either going to
say yes I'm able to or no I'm not if you
realize you are able if you have an
understanding of this potential this
power within you then you have to ask
yourself are you willing and there's a
long series of tests there you don't
even know what you're going to come up
against one thing is for certain you'll
come up against ridicule you may have to
move
you may have to do all kinds of things
that you don't even think about you have
to be willing to do whatever is required
if you really want to turn your fantasy
into a fact that that can you say yes I
am willing at that instant you've
created your theory
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because it will kill
birth we do so there's a single transfer
that is do you want me to profound max
check out the link in the description
you can go and cast your vote alpha must
know which Clips resonance and most of
you what lesson you're going to teach
this video and immediately apply to your
life or to business somehow leave it in
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out what you have to say I was
going to give a quick chatter to squad
minions thank you so much ready for
picking up 10 copies up my club share it
with your friends and posting that
awesome review on Amazon I really
appreciate the support me in a really
glasses to enjoy but thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you hope
you teach to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
your present or past results have
absolutely nothing to do with what's
going to happen from this point forward
now that was the point that race Canfor
drilled into my head you see I kept
thinking well gee I such a mess up you
know I've done everything wrong up till
now I'm 26 I'm broke I'm not happy
everything was wrong he said Bob that's
all in the past he said every moment is
a new moment we shouldn't condemn
ourselves and he said what you were
yesterday you paid for what you are
today you decide what that's exactly
what troll' would say this power in no
way is limited by precedent even in a
creative state we sometimes don't
understand that you know why airplanes
right up to today almost have wings on
them because birds have wings birds fly
they have wings it's going to get a
plane to fly you got to put wings on it
do you know we've got planes flying
without wings today you know why never
didn't need wings but you see the
thinking was to a degree limited by
precedent birds fly with wings planes
have to have wings planes do not have to
have wings you're creative if you can
visualize it you can do it it doesn't
matter what it is that's what Hill said
it doesn't even mind can conceive and
believe it can achieve you see the
beautiful part about goals and
understanding it is goals are not to get
goals is not you do set goals for
acquisition you set goals to grow you
set goals to reach inside and stretch
and go where you've never been
you set goals to take into a place
you've never gone before and you grow as
your human being and you know something
you never go back
choice is one of the most important
concepts that you can get we're going to
be talking about the laws of the
universe one of the laws is a law
clarity there'd be note inside to the
room you're in if there was an outside
you couldn't have a right side your body
with outer left or a top of the bottom
or
from without a vac you can't have a band
without a good see the truth is we make
it better good Ralph Waldo trying in
tune with the infinite a great book he
said nothing is good or bad except our
thinking will majors so well if
everything is both good and bad and we
bring it together what's right in the
center if everything here is bad
everything here is good what's in the
center just is everything just is you
choose whether you're going to look at
the downside of the upside michael
beckwith gave me a marvelous concept he
said it doesn't matter what happens in
your life doesn't matter what happens
you can't control the circumstance but
you can certainly control how you deal
with them he said when anything happens
step number one it is what it is accept
it it's either going to control you or
you're going to control it that's a
choice step number two harvest the good
isn't that a neat word harvest harvest
the good there's good and bad and
everything just harvest the good step
number three forgive all the rest
forgive means like go up completely it's
a choice yet if you let go of the bed
the good seems to grow you and I have a
choice it may be a difficult choice
sometimes if you're dealing with a
particularly difficult circumstance
nevertheless
we've got the power within us to do it
so as you go through the day doesn't
matter what anybody says doesn't matter
what happens you have a choice to say
that's good W Clement stone became the
wealthiest man in the United States of
America by 1970 because he always said
that's good doesn't matter what it was
he'd say that's good and then you'd look
for the good that's a good choice for
you to make and make it all day long so
your word for the day is choice choice
choice and only you have the ability to
do that and if you choose right you are
going to get results that stick